So now that we understand what factors
were multiplied together to create this
term, is there a more simplified way for
us to write this? Thankfully the answer is
yes. However before we can start to play
around with this term, we need to learn
about something called the commutative
property. Specifically the commutative
property of multiplication, since all of
our factors are multiplied together here.
The commutative property of multiplication
basically tells us that it doesn't matter
what order you multiply things together
in. So, for example we know that 2 times 3 =
6. However, we also know that 3 times 2 = 6.
That means we know that 2 times 3 is just equal to 3
times 2. If you want to talk about this with
variables instead of with numbers we could
talk about, let's say, x times z times y. Here we
have three different variables multiplied
together and we can rearrange these
factors in any order we want and still get
a mathematically equivalant expression. So
we could have, a ton of different things
maybe z times x times y. That's also equal to y times x times z
or z times y times x, and so on and so forth. All
these expressions and all the other ones
that we could get, by rearranging these in
other ways are equal to one another. So
remember for multiplication, it doesn't
matter what order you multiply things
together in. This holds no matter how many
things you want to multiply together, and
it holds whether the factors are variables
or numbers.